Lode Bloomberg radio and television
political reporter John Warnock Ellen
Moran of emily's list and Peter til of
the independent Institute and a ten live
campaign 96 coverage of the Reform Party
of Virginia State Conference will hear
remarks from Ross Perot and former
Colorado Governor Richard lamb next a
news conference on women voters and the
Republican Party will hear from
Republican pollster Kelly Anne
Fitzpatrick and the vice president of
communications and the legislative
director for the group Concerned Women
for America the host of this 50 minute
event
good morning and thank you for joining
us my name is Carmen paid and I'm vice
president of communications for
Concerned Women for America Concerned
Women for America is the nation's
largest political women's activist group
we have 600,000 members nationwide and
through our grassroots efforts we stand
for family values and family issues on
Capitol Hill making a difference for the
lives of families and with me today is
also our legislative director from
Concerned Women for America penny young
Nance and then we are also privileged to
have with us Kelly M Fitzpatrick with
Esquire who obvious president of the
polling company and also an analyst with
CNN we're anxious to hear her comments
as well our format today I'll speak for
a few moments and then following the
both keaney and kelly will speak for
approximately 10 minutes and then we'll
open the open the discussion up for
questions so you can be preparing for
that we're going to examine today where
the women's vote is going to be going in
November of 1996 and why and what both
parties can do beginning today to swing
that vote in their direction there's a
lot of talk right now in the news in the
media about the gender gap and we
believe that the election outcomes will
will be determined by the women's vote
and we want to dispel today what the gap
has traditionally been viewed as and let
you know from our opinions and also from
a Wirthlin study poll that was done
earlier in the year what women are
really thinking we have found that
traditionally women have changed their
mind often throughout a political
campaign who they will vote for when you
ask what party affiliate that they are
with they will traditionally stay
Democrat but we have seen there there's
always
some pendulum swing throughout the
campaign and then on election day we
actually see them moving to a more
conservative vote we found that to be
true in the 1984 elections when 55
percent of the vote went to reagan in
nineteen eighty eight fifty two percent
of the vote went to bush and in nineteen
ninety two forty six percent went to
clinton and of course the remaining was
divided the Wirthlin study group
commissioned ab commissioned by CWA
earlier this year confirmed that over
half of american women do in fact
consider themselves to be conservative
compared to only three and ten who say
they are liberal and only one in ten who
consider themselves to be moderate and
what party affiliation do they claim to
hold democrat forty percent how do the
candidates fare in light of the issues
that are most important to women well
what are the most important issues of
women we asked what is the single most
important problem facing america today
and they mentioned next to crime the
most important issue was the decline in
moral values and when you consider that
issue and what that means what social
concerns really are discussing moral
values weird we believe that character
is extremely important to the american
women and if women were going to vote on
that issue today without a doubt dole
would win hands down but what about the
other issues the democrats win in the
public relations battle here to the
detriment of the republicans the clinton
campaign team is targeting the women
vote and their campaign strategy once
again if you will refer to the Wirthlin
study that we have given you in your
packages today studies show that women
favor a tough-love approach to welfare
and this is quite surprising because
most often it is assumed that women are
so compassionate that they would not be
for a tough-love approach but in fact
they are compassionate at 68
percent favor the family cat 72% favor
establishing paternity before welfare
benefits are given 69 percent favor
limiting cash payments on to two years
Clinton is even willing to battle his
own party leaders on the welfare issue
because he knows that this is important
to the women's vote penny is going to
dress shortly some other issues like
abortion like same-sex marriage but
these two are issues where Clinton has
co-opted the Republican campaign the
Democrats are politically savvy they're
moving away from their traditional
liberal strategies to more conservative
strategies on issues that are most
important to women but the real sleeper
issue and the one that we want to hit
home on today is education this is an
issue that the Republicans have not even
spoken a word of until only a couple of
days ago and we applied Oh for coming
out with his stance on education the
Democrats have been talking about
education since day one but what are the
Democrats saying what are they telling
us when they do talk to us well we don't
see any programs that have been
announced that will improve the quality
of education we've seen a demand for
more money we know that mr. Clinton is
now beholden to the NEA and we know that
the NEA it's totally out of touch with
the American women and again we're
referring back to our polls the NEA has
has endorsed more control of public
schools whereas American women believe
that control should be in the family
should have the print parents should
have the rights over the education of
their children they should have the
right to choose the school for their
children dole has the advantage here
with the voters because after breaking
his silence on the issue he has spoken
in favor of more parental control and
school choice in education either party
could take this issue at this point and
run with it the more moderate and
liberal women see education as an
equalizing force in their race for power
more conservative women see education is
a most critical issue for their
children's future this is an issue that
is a sleeper issue and we believe that
both parties have an opportunity to gain
the women's vote if they speak out and
if their record shows that they are and
truly in favor of better education for
our children
I'd like to turn the program at this
point over to penny and again Kelley
will follow and then I'll wrap up I'm
penny Young Nance I'm director of
legislation and public policy for
Concerned Women for America I have a
statement available if you'd like to get
a copy of that before you leave
Concerned Women for America has always
known that the majority of American
women are conservative on the issues
this poll only confirmed what we already
knew to be true we have always found it
to be ironic that women of the extreme
ideological left like for instance Pat
Schroeder have been often traditionally
the source of the media and politicians
look to for guidance on women's issues
American women are pro-life pro-family
tired of taxes and sick of a broken
welfare system and any party that
panders to the National Organization of
a few women will lose so what is the
winning strategy its centers around
communication the candidates that looks
women in the eye and clearly articulates
his or her conservative principles on
the issues will gain their support I've
spoken with members of Congress who are
running for re-election who've said to
me you know other than the issue of
breast cancer research I don't really
know how to appeal the women voters well
here's the clue 80% of American women
polled said that they would prefer to
stay home and be a full-time mom if they
could afford it economically Congress
was right when they passed the $500 per
child tax credit when they passed IRA
equity when they got rid of the marriage
penalty the President's veto of those
measures for anti-woman
Congress needs to be vigilant in their
efforts to repass those same measures
and they need to go further in lowering
taxes the average American family today
pays over 30% of their income to the
government in taxes that's why many
American women fight tears every morning
as they grab the briefcase and leave
their baby at home to go to an overrated
job that they prefer not to be in
parents should be the ones to decide
whether to be a two-income family or not
not the government's overburdening tax
policy candidates had been led to
believe that the majority of women are
pro-abortion
interesting enough though recent surveys
are showing that the most pro-abortion
group in America are white single males
between the ages of 21 and 35 I believe
that that statistic points to drastic
black of personal responsibility on the
other end however our poll the Wirthlin
poll showed that 55% of American women
believed abortion should only be legal
with either a live only exception or a
rape incest life of the mother exception
of the forty five percent of American
women that we polled that consider
themselves pro-choice sixty-nine percent
said they wanted restrictions after the
first trimester and another nine percent
said they weren't restrictions after the
second trimester that means that a full
79 Persis in 78 percent of American
women support the partial birth abortion
ban Act the president was not in line
with American women when he vetoed the
partial birth abortion ban act we urge
Congress though to override his veto and
to protect children against this vile
procedure in addition women take a
tough-love approach to welfare reform an
overwhelming number of women's support
attorney establishment as a requirement
for payments they support work
requirements they support the family cap
and they support limiting payments for
two years
although liberals will say because women
are compassionate they do not support
welfare reform I
say because they are compassionate they
support welfare reform the current
welfare system is anything but
compassionate it has trapped women
children in the system that robs them of
their potential instills their dreams
the welfare system has contributed to
general a generation of fatherless
children that are more likely to drop
out of school to commit suicide to
become involved in drugs to become a
victim of or part of violent crime and
to become pregnant out of wedlock these
children also three times more likely to
become a welfare sipping and as an adult
and that she have the cycle of welfare
dependency the children that I have
mentored an inner-city DC hardly know
anyone that is married the out of
wedlock birth rate in DC is somewhere
around 74 percent at this time and
higher in some neighborhoods until this
desperate cultural epidemic is addressed
the issue of crime will remain at the
top of concern for American women and it
is only compassionate for Congress to
pass the Republican welfare reform act
that is currently up before the House
and Senate women support it and it's
good for America and finally the vast
majority of American women do not
support same-sex marriage CWA applauds
the recent passage of the Defense of
Marriage Act in the house and we urge
the Senate to do the same before the
August recess the issues I've mentioned
are winning issues a challenge
conservatives to clearly articulate
their positions and I challenge American
women to educate themselves on the
issues concern from Concerned Women for
America we'll continue our work to
educate women through our publications
through voters guides and through our
daily radio show thank you
kelly-ann if you'd like to come here
please thank you very much and looking
at the woman's vote in 1996 I think it's
less instructive to look at current
polling data is and more instructive as
a way to see where women will go to see
where they've been before if you look at
past voting behavior among women you see
very little deviation for example in the
last 16 years of congressional elections
women have given the Democratic
candidate in their district fifty five
four fifty five fifty four percent of
the vote in six out of eight elections
the greatest fluctuation in year to year
has been about three or four points men
on the other hand have fluctuated
between six and seven points in about
three or four of the elections and I
think in an electoral climate where both
sides of the aisle agree that women are
more risk-averse and than ever and less
connected to things Washington and that
it's you're hard-pressed to imagine a
situation where women will deviate from
what's been a pretty consistent pattern
a self-identified pattern it's very
ironic that we speak of how relating to
women here in Washington because our
polls and we conducted one finish just
this week 800 women nationwide our polls
show that neither the faith nor nor
their role models among women right now
survive much from Washington DC I think
that the party and in this regard I
would say the Republican Party has done
the best job in this Congress of
strengthening women's relationships with
the non political institutions that
matter most in their life their families
their places of worship their places of
work and and the individuals with which
they deal day in and day out women are
very community-based individuals which
makes them very local thinking voters
they are more likely to know what's
going on the local school board or even
the recent water tax hike they're more
likely to know things that truly affect
the home their children and their
families than they are to be paying
attention to more national issues that
does not mean a mutually exclusive
I'm merely
showing you that if any gender gap
exists at all it's in two areas the
difference between national and local
concerns among men and women which is
also explained through paper readership
women like 13 percent 13 percentage
points behind men in terms of reading a
national newspaper however they're more
likely to get their news from a TV
network or from word-of-mouth the oral
tradition of women would back that up
and the second thing about the gender
gap I think most important if it exists
at all it really exists as between the
way men and women knew the role of
governments and that has changed over
time as well traditionally women have
had one of the more active activists
federal government you see that waning a
bit but at the same time the male
approach to an activist government has
been eroding even quick more quickly so
I'll give you some statistics when you
ask women if they would prefer a
complete overhaul of government and a
complete and downsizing quickly they're
more likely to go for the second choice
which is meaningful reforms I've done at
it at a common sense speed very few of
them still pick the ones don't change
things too quickly make a very slow go
approach but it's somewhere between
drastic overhaul and the rhetoric of
revolution and and dramatic overnight
change and doing nothing at all
protecting the status quo this is what
women want from government over time the
view among many women in this country
that the government should be a provider
of security has been modified a great
deal women now believe that the
government should be an insurer of
security but not a direct link between
themselves and what they need in their
everyday lives what has replaced the
what was once a larger need for security
from the government a larger desire for
security from the government it's very
placed in part by opportunity and women
really do expect from the federal
government a combination of ensuring
security and providing opportunity and I
would back up the comments made by the
other women on the panel by saying it is
unequivocally true quantifiably in
polling numbers that women want a less
activist government where they believe
their role should
for example and our testing on education
and welfare by margins of more than two
to one
women prefer the Republican solutions to
the problems and except when you call
them the Republican solutions to
problems in blind polling when you say
would you prefer this approach or this
approach women always gravitate towards
the approach that allows them greater
control over their children's curriculum
allows them a greater say in choosing
where their children go to school and
allows the able-bodied people to return
to work after a certain time certain and
and I would say this year the Republican
and Democrats in Congress gave President
Clinton a bill that that he refused to
sign that he in fact nito that would
have provided 2.2 billion dollars more
in child care benefits for welfare
mothers who want to return to work than
what President Clinton had asked for and
he vetoed that I think that the gender
gap as it has been covered this year the
near hysterical coverage of the gender
gap this year is probably second only to
the most obsessed issue award which I
would have to award to the issue of
abortion as it's been covered but it's
it's a close race and I would point to
when we asked in a closed-ended question
what is the most important issue to you
personally and we close under the
question jobs and economy crime welfare
education health care abortion abortion
came in dead last jobs and economy came
in first followed by education health
care welfare at crime welfare and
abortion the thing is that abort this
this poll seems to back up a poll that
was conducted by ms magazine in 1992 by
my democratic polling colleague celinda
Lake that poll showed that when you
asked women an open-ended question
what's the most important challenge you
face as a woman in everyday life not
surprisingly 40% said balancing the
needs of work and family underscoring
Penney's comment that most women have
given the economic opportunity would
prefer to race or have the option of
raising their children themselves but
abortion came in at 1% it was number 20
on the list
it was dead last and that is because
when women think of immediate security
concerns they think of job security
economic security for themselves and
their children
not so much balancing the federal budget
as much as balancing the family budget
as that is expressed to checkbooks and
through the difficult position of having
to explain to to six-year-old Johnny why
he can't have the toy he's seen on TV or
why he can't attend the school that his
best friend is attending along the same
lines we asked a question open-ended
what in your mind is the best way to
reduce crime in this country and when we
could have said anything they wanted
topping the list was a combination of
strengthening families more religious
education and morality all those
combined came in at 17% gun laws was at
5% and in between there is education is
abolition of parole stronger sentencing
more police on the street and issues
like that women are starting to shift a
bit from their preventative approaches
to climb and go for the punitive
approaches to crime that have so long
been a hallmark of the way men approach
true criminal solutions in this country
I'll close on this note I think that
Republicans should be very concerned
about some of the current polling
statistics but I would cost about the
woman's vote but I would caution on
several areas number one similar
hysteria about the Mars versus Venus
distinction in 1994 in 1992 or precious
little resemblance to the eventual
outcomes
women are very late in the game deciders
arguably our country's busiest people
thinking considering home and work their
two workplaces now they they will focus
on this election about 80 loads of
laundry and about 50 interoffice memos
from now and with their opinions
solidifying after Labor Day July and
August are important times for a
political party to trumpet their the
past accomplishments and future
commitment to the women of this country
when you ask women what is most
important to them in deciding for whom
to run for president positions on the
issues is over twice the number of
anything else it's followed by character
leadership past
some record political affiliation barely
gets an asterisk with which in polling
vernacular is less than 1% so women will
be looking at the positions on the
issues along those same lines we asked
women if all you knew about a candidate
as long as Republican one was a Democrat
for whom which you would vote Democrat
has an advantage within the margin of
error the number one response is the one
women volunteered in the poll which is
it makes a difference I need to know
more about those two individuals that
statistic coupled with the fact that
over 40% of women will look most towards
positions on the issues of candidates in
deciding for whom to vote means that
this game is still wide open among women
I do think the window of opportunity is
narrowing as time goes on but after the
children are back in school and after
the conventions have first picked the
visual interest of many women in this
country as a way toward then
understanding the message of the
respective political parties and their
candidates that is the time for us to
really watch the last point I'd like to
make is that strictly as a geeky
pollster which is I believe 100% of
women's grievances and expectations are
represented in accurate polls but in a
country such as ours only about 55 or 60
percent of those women will turn out and
vote this year and that in my mind is
the difference between art which is
measured so early in an election cycle
and the actual science and nuts and
bolts of election day thank you thank
you Kellyanne and penny just a comment
follow up on your comments cally
regarding the abortion issue our pose
agreed with kellyanne's poll that that
abortion is not the top concern of
American women even as a matter of fact
only about 1% of the women who were
polled in the Wirthlin study felt that
that was an issue that was most
important that needed to be addressed
however the one percent who did feel
that it was important were pro-life and
is important to remember that pro lifers
vote pro-life and so that is something
that that the candidates do need to
consider also it is important to
remember as Kelly mentioned that we
still have four months before the
election we have two conventions coming
up and
women do change their mind and being a
woman I can say that without feeling
embarrassed about that we do change our
mind and the reason is because our
families are so important to us our
children's future and their education is
of utmost importance and because of that
we are not going to vote for a candidate
who does not address those issues who
does not talk about those issues and
they have to do more than talk we have
to see that there's been action in their
past that demonstrates that they not
only talk the talk but that they walk
the talk and we really believe that if
the candidates both Democrats and
Republicans would keep harping on
education on welfare on tax reform on
those you know allowing those women who
desire to stay at home with their
families make it easier on and show them
how you're going to do it show them how
education is going to be improved that
56% of those students I just found out
in in the Washington DC area who were
graduating many could not even read
their diplomas these are issues that
American women are concerned about and
the candidates have four months to
convince the the women of America not
only that what they believe about the
issues but they have to make their story
believable to the women women have got
to believe the candidates so who's going
to win it's going to be the one who not
only talks the issues it's going to be
the one who is most believable it's
going to be the one that addresses the
issues that are most of our most
importance to women welfare crime
education so we'll wait and see our
point today is is that there is there is
a lot of time there is a lot of time for
both candidates to make some moves in
the right direction to win the women's
vote we can we will believe I believe
that we'll be continuing to see it a
pendulum swing back and forth I believe
that more and more women will begin to
get involved in the campaigns as the
conventions come about and they may
change their ideas in the polls several
times but on elec
their decision will be made and we
believe that once again we will see that
women are going to vote on the candidate
who has gone with the conservative
issues conservative stands on
conservative issues at this time I'd
like to open up for questions to our
panel and I'll ask a Kelly if you need
to come to the podium so they can can
hear you clearly any questions from from
the audience
yes any of you who want to could tackle
this question this pretender uh you have
President Clinton and Bob Dole's ear
what advice would you give each one
individually about what they should do
compared to where they are now someone
asked me that question yesterday about
Bob Dole and I had already had an answer
already at that point I think that the
the polling data that showed that eighty
percent of American women would prefer
to be at home if they could afford it
economically is overwhelming and if Bob
Dole would make a point of pointing out
the tax policy changes that he would
like to make the economic incentives
that he would like to give in order for
American women to reach their own goal
in order for a mom and dad to decide as
I said before whether to or not to be a
two-income family um I am this is
particularly hitting home for me because
I am actually a mother-to-be
also and I am going through this exact
dilemma today and my husband are
crunching the numbers and looking at our
budgets and saying what can we do
because I would prefer to stay at home
and be with my baby then dropping him or
her off every morning in a daycare
center it's must I I really feel for the
women how heartbreaking it must be for
the ones that would like to stay home
that absolutely cannot and so I would
just appeal to Republicans to articulate
that message in their vision for the tax
policy we should not be paying 30% of
our income to the proper government and
the only work that's valued in this
country as far as the issue of our a
equity many of you all may not know
about that issue are a equity today is
is a huge issue in senator kay Bailey
Hutchinson has tried to address this
issue with a bill that would change the
current policy today if you are a
two-income family you can deduct $4,000
for your IRA however if one of you stay
home you get a pittance of
250 dollars for that that person who
stays home the other person can do
$2,000 so it's two thousand two hundred
and fifty dollars and that doesn't sound
like a lot that's seventeen hundred
dollars maybe you could say that maybe
you couldn't but if you could over a
40-year period at about a 6% interest
rate that's about two hundred and eighty
seven thousand dollars that you're being
cheated because one of you chooses to
stay at home or needs to stay home so
that is basically discriminatory against
women that want to stay at home or
choose to see on with their children and
often sacrifice to do that that's not
fair it's not right and the marriage
penalty as well needs to be changed and
so we need to we need to make those
changes in the tax policy that will
level the playing field that will
particularly considering the problems
that we have today in our culture we
have a huge explosion in in minor crime
and violent crime among minors we have a
huge problem out of wedlock births I
think all those problems can be
partially attributed to the fact that
mom and I don't have as much time
anymore
just spend with them and so if we're
going to address the concerns of
families and can dress the concerns of
women then you're gonna have to address
the tax policy and articulate your
message on it well Brett I would give
him the same advice although I don't
don't believe that he would be as open
to tanning it the same policies that
I've outlined for either candidate are
winning issues and so Bill Clinton wants
to win he's gonna have to change this
position on a number of issues I think
also in the same regard the issue of
education is one that both candidates
need to address since the establishment
of the Department of Education millions
of tax dollars have gone to fund that
department and yet since the inception
of the Department of Education SAT
scores have continued to decline we have
seen a change in standards for our
children rather than keeping the
standards high and ensuring that they
receive the education that they need to
meet those standards I believe that if
both candidates take a look at
dismantling the
Department of Education that would be a
step in the right direction put those
tax dollars back into the states back
into the communities where the schools
can become once again what they used to
be so that parents can have more control
more responsibility and they can choose
they can choose where their children
will go to school
I know efforts in again in the DC area
where there was an opportunity to have a
three thousand dollar scholarship for
elementary or high school students to go
to a school of choice that was was put
down immediately by the National
Education Association and I believe the
only reason that they fought against
that was because that means that once
again schools would have to do the job
that they know to do to to encourage
those kids to come to their schools they
would they would create competition also
it would encourage students to raise
their standards that encourage parents
become more involved and and I think
that's certainly something that the
National Education Association and the
Department of Education are not for so
education is an issue again where both
candidates could make a difference any
other questions I apologize I came in a
little late so you may have addressed
this in the course of your polling are
you finding out any particular problems
that women have with either dole or
Clinton is there anything specific that
bothers women about either one of the
two candidates Kelly did your powell
specifically talk about the individual
candidates okay
I think the most instructive answer I
can give to that question would come
through a series of open-ended questions
when you ask people what's the first
thing that springs to mind when you
think of Republican when you think of
Democrat what seems to bother women
mostly about Bob Dole is that even
though they know who he is he has about
110 percent name idea across this
country they are hard pressed to name a
couple of accomplishments that they
would a said that they would attribute
to him or positions on issues in which
they care about that they're still not
sure where he stands on them and so with
that I would give senator Dole advice
that you're not message challenged at
all its dissemination of that message
because if I were Bob Dole you'd
probably stand up and pick four simple
issues that were passed by Democrats and
Republicans well he was majority leader
of the Senate he had bipartisan support
arrived at President Clinton's desk he
said no way those would include the
homemaker IRA that penny just talked
about the $500 per child tax credit that
would have allowed saying expectant and
expectant family like pennies I'm glad
to hear that for the first time here to
buy a new crib or maybe some things for
the baby $500 in post tax money the
third would be the fact that Republicans
and Democrats well Bob Dole was Majority
Leader passed legislation that would
have provided for self-employed pension
funds that's significant to this
nation's women one-third of all small
businesses now earn it aren't owned by
women they own 8 million small
businesses nationwide they employ 1/4 of
the nation's total workforce that's
significant stuff and the fourth one
would be the welfare bills that I
mentioned before and have been mentioned
by all three women this morning in
different contexts but I think most
specifically to explain to women that
Democrats and Republicans while Bob Dole
was in charge of the Senate passed in
excess of 2.2 billion dollars in child
care benefits for welfare mothers if
they would return to work because many
welfare mothers will tell you that they
don't want their dignity and pride sack
one more moment they want to return to
work but their fear is who will watch
their children they've been doing it
this would have provided them the
services
the benefits they needed while they get
their feet back on the ground um the
problem that women have with Clinton
I'll read you some poor leadership for a
character a pretty good on environment
but I don't necessarily know what he
means
open-minded higher tax isn't giving
everything away interested in the public
these are some of the problems they have
I will say here I think that there is a
bit of a hidden a formative hidden
anti-clinton vote among women today
because it comes up in every single
polling statistic except for the ballot
test and the nation's women are very
responsible citizens who don't think
it's cachet to attack a president and
head on in a polling question that's
understandable
a George Bush Ronald Reagan Jimmy Carter
they all benefited from that same as
same phenomenon but in other polling
questions where you see more than one
half of the nation's female voters say
they believe that President Clinton lied
about his affair and Whitewater it takes
an awful lot for women in this country
to say they believe their president has
lied even a larger number of them
believe that the FBI files were obtained
for for improper purposes why is this
significant it's significant because
whereas women were not so concerned
about immediately concerned about
whitewater from the beginning or even
the Paula Jones matter because they
bought into the criteria that these were
things that didn't happen here and
didn't happen while he were president he
was president these newest flaps at the
White House the FBI of the FBI filed
problems also the travelgate problems
they did happen here and they did happen
while he was in office and this makes
women buy into a little bit more of
their own ideas is something I heard in
the focus group in Seattle of women
recently which is that I don't feel
proud to have them as my president
anymore
and I think if all of that ends up
forming into votes then I would say that
done mister Clinton isn't some electoral
trouble in addition to the hidden
anti-clinton vote that is in its early
formation stages and may not may not
amount to much but is starting to be
there I would say that the real fear we
have this year is that instead of
deciding for whom to vote women will
decide not to vote and there'll be a bit
of self vote repression one positive
note on that is that in the same poll we
asked women to describe which was more
like the way they feel about their vote
you vote because you think it makes a
difference you vote because it's you
know you should it's your duty as an
American or you vote even though you
don't think it makes much of a
difference and almost half said they
believe their vote does make a
difference which i think is quite
encouraging also along the lines of the
character issue you know parents are
looking for role models for their
children and when they are teaching
values to their children it seems almost
automatic that you would be able to
point to the president and say here is
someone of character and when the
majority of the American people today
say that he has no character how can
they point to that person and say he is
a role model to follow
so character is important because we are
looking for role models for our children
we want to be able to say the people who
run this country do have character and
and that's something that right now is
very difficult to find also I wanted to
mention along the voting issue and it is
it true the women that we surveyed a
thousand women nationwide who said that
83% of them were registered to vote 82%
of them had voted and most in the most
recent election and one of the things
that we are doing a concern woman for
America is using our grassroots effort
of those six hundred thousand members
nationwide to get out there and to talk
to women to make sure that they are
educated on the issues to make sure that
they are registered to vote to make sure
that they know what candidates stand for
what issues and we will be encouraging
them every day between now and election
to get out there and vote and to
encourage their family to do the same
and again to look for these issues so so
if they haven't voted in the past I can
assure your we're going to make sure
they get out there this year and both
candidates from both parties better be
aware that the women are gonna vote this
year and they're going to be looking at
the conservative person who represents
them lest any other questions yes
Calahan Clinton has been talking about
education and Bob Dole just started
talking about it up in Wisconsin can Bob
Dole use the education issue to help
close the gender gap I think education
is probably the fastest admission to get
toward winning the women's vote this
year and I am very pleased that Bob Dole
has begun to talk about it in some real
policy programmatic specifics the
problem I would see with the way
President Clinton has handled the
education issue is in this poll also we
tested it it say not saying well most
doles position wellness Clinton's but
just laying out candidate one believes
this about education candidate two
believes this and women by more than two
to one went toward the candidate who
would allow parents greater control over
their children's curriculum and and a
greater say in the choice of where their
children go to school as opposed to one
who believes that the federal government
should have a role in education and and
that it's it's okay for teachers to have
as much control over a child's
curriculum as parents I think that on it
would be wonderful for Bob Dole to take
the reins of what's happening at the
grassroots level across this country in
28 states over the next year or two
you're going to hear about parental
rights and responsibilities either
amendment as they have in Colorado
initiatives referendum and of course
congressman Steve Largent from Oklahoma
has some federal legislation all it says
is that parents should have the right to
direct rights and responsibilities to
direct the education upbringing of their
children it's all it says it's almost
like the grass is green the sky is blue
piece of legislation but it's
significant amidst a climate where so
many Americans feel that education is
the root cause of so many of the
problems in our society and on the flip
side provides the key to many of the
solutions to that you always hear people
especially in qualitative focus groups
when you say you know well how would you
solve that better education and to you
it may mean a frontal assault on the
public schools to her it may mean making
sure that workforce is a skilled one to
someone else that may mean that parents
don't feel like they give up the rights
over their children when they drop them
off it's
in the morning until they pick them up
at 3:00 and I think one of the problems
is that President Clinton or even all
over the board with education instead of
coming out and say here's who here's why
I'm on education it's been a tax credit
here and tuition sent us here and
uniforms there and give everyone a
computer and now I guess a cell phone
over there and I think that the
candidate either mister dole or mr.
Clinton comes out and says here are my
four policy prescriptions of what to do
on education it will probably carry the
day because the ground is fertile for
candidates to excuse me for voters to
hear who the next education president
will be and adding to that I know the
parental rights and responsibilities Act
came up as an issue in Boston here just
a week or so ago and I was talking with
a radio host in that area who was saying
at that moment there were hundreds of
parents who were protesting to make them
not protesting excuse me speaking on
behalf of their children and saying that
we have a right to determine our
children's education we need we have a
right to have that choice of Education
so education as I mentioned earlier is a
sleeper issue it is one that both
candidates certainly need to jump on and
me need to make some decisions that are
hard-hitting and believable one last
question if or ssin is dead last in
significance and those women who do vote
on it are pro-life then where does all
this emphasis on pro-choice Republican
women come from dole acts as if they're
an important constituency is a getting
bad advice and if Ann stone and
Republicans for choice don't speak for
women who are they speaking for well you
know it's an interesting point that you
make that you would think listening to
much of the media that it is the number
one issue and it's just it's also the
fact you know the now organization has
approximately 200,000 members we triple
in size but yet you hear from hear of
them almost every day in the news and
you hardly ever hear of Concerned Women
for America and I think partly because
they're they have a liberal voice and
sometimes they they gather the liberal
ear and and sometimes the the squeaky
will is the loudest and I believe that
they have you
the abortion issue to try to tear apart
the Republican Party but you know we
also see that issue addressed in the
Democratic Party there is also some
concern there's conversation about
putting tolerance in their language just
as they're talking about tolerance in
the Republican plank so it's it's an all
across-the-board issue those who are
pro-life vote pro-life and they're there
they are they are strong in their
convictions they do not sway from their
convictions but but women are more
concerned at this point about other
other priorities like the other issues
we've mentioned today absolutely
follow-up Annette briefly I think that
the fact that Bob Dole is 100% pro-life
voting record and actually seems to
stand on the issue of abortion once in a
while is really a shame because it would
it would seem to me that he's receiving
miscues from people who perhaps would
not have had a 100% pro-life voting
record if they had been a senator from
Kansas for all those years and I would
think that with all due respect to my
friends I think that I'm whenever
whenever someone has a vested interest
in something in Washington one must look
at what else is going there and there's
a lot of money to be made to be on a
certain side of an issue in this town
and I think that it's it's it's an
honest part of the debate to discuss
abortion rights in this country but I
would all boil it down to the scene
versus the unseen you are not going to
find a homemaker in Wichita Kansas who
knows exactly how she's voting this year
has always been pro-life and is now
started their own home business but a
still pro-life and it's still important
to her you're not gonna find her on the
Larry King Live show you're not gonna
find her going out to a protest she is
the unseen element and she numbers in
the millions in this country but it's
the seen elements it's and I think it's
the squeaking squeaky's wheels that get
all the grease pre-election but again it
all comes down to who turns out and
maybe some people will be too busy
responding to media calls to actually
vote that day but I can guarantee you
people like the woman in Wichita will be
at the polls by 7:00 a.m.
I also think that we cannot forget about
the activists the people that are
actually out walking the precincts for
either candidate and the truth of the
matter is that the pro-life element of
the Republican Party that the moms
pushing the strollers across America are
the activists that can't write the big
checks for the candidate but they're
also the one that's out walking the
precinct doing her volunteer work answer
the phone stuffing envelopes and if BOM
Dole walks away from that issue if he
weakens the pro-life plank and if he
does not pick a pro-life running mate
will alienate that part of the party
they may still vote for him but they
will not give up their time they will
not work at the precinct
they will not stuff the stuff the
envelopes so it would be a mistake it
would be terrible advice for Bob Dole to
pander to that very small part of the
party who screams about being pro-choice
and to neglect his base which is the
pro-life Republicans in the pro-life
women